all right liberal cities have another
brilliant idea on how to fight crime and
stop the violent surge of carjackings
and no it's not locking up dangerous
repeat criminals Washington DC mayor
Muriel Bowser is handing out free air
tags to Residents to make it easier to
track their stolen car more more
seriously these tags and tiles will help
MPD recover stolen vehicles and hold
people accountable the word will also
get out that this is not a community to
come in and steal cars um because it it
won't be worth your while right we'll
eventually find you we're not sure how
Apple Air tags will make a dent in the
Staggering number of thefts happening in
our nation's capital look at that number
up 36% the number of stolen cars up
significantly mayor bowo however should
get credit on this she is slamming a DC
judge for sending a 15-year-old
carjacking suspect home after her
seventh carjacking
arrests does not make that decision
judges do and is the judge's right to
say I prefer shelter and if I can't get
a shelter then I'm going send this child
home the child was sent
home the child is now not with us
unbelievable and she's a danger again
Katie let's start with you do you think
these Mayors have to change their stance
on going easy on crime not Prosecuting
crime because they have to deal with
this on a daily basis do you see them
saying hey I I admit I blew it my heart
was in the right place but my head isn't
my the St may have to do it the city
council has to make the penalties more
intense they actually made the penalties
less for carjacking recently uh the
judges and the juries had to put people
behind bars you know the Washington
posted the story this week about this
woman who already had an air tag in her
car yeah and she got car jacked so she
has on her phone with the police
watching over her shoulder and she's
watching it drive around and she said
are you going to go get it and they said
no we can't pursue so until the car is
stopped they can't actually go get the
car but the bigger issue here is that
over the weekend there was another
carjacking 827 carjackings in Washington
DC this year alone think about how many
per day that is it was a 13-year-old and
a 12-year-old and it was an off-duty
Federal Officer who ended up shooting
the 13-year-old died the 12-year-old was
then taken away 74% of the carard
jackings involve guns and the majority
of them are people under 18 so the issue
is that juveniles are getting away with
these horrendous crimes 12year olds and
13y olds should not be out at 10 p.m. on
the weekend without a parent or a
guardian they have to figure out this
problem with young people deciding to be
involved in this horrific crime which is
a crime but also it's it's horrible that
13-year-olds have to suffer a fate that
they rightly deserved if they're going
to carjack people and say they have a a
weapon but that is something that the
city council should have have to deal
with so Harold it seems that the air tag
idea is something that we found in the
80s with lowjack uh lowjack tracks your
car so Henry quar actually left his
Airtech in his car after he was
carjacked and they ended up getting it
back what do you think about her uh uh
is she getting to her wits end on this
do you see her changing her stance on
this I hope so look I I don't mind the
use of new technology this is not going
to change the things we're talking about
but at least you you might be a small
deter couple things we we we've talked
before it there are four things you need
to do to try to deal with crime I think
in in in these cities and and Katie
you've T talked about this as well first
you got to end cashless baell uh it's
not working um I was one from the outset
that thought that there might be some
benefit but it has not turned out to be
a benefit and I think you have to be
responsible say it's not working too um
the the the The lethality of some of
these guns that are allowed on the
street we should ban assault weapons uh
we should figure out we should you may
not like they're not they're notjing
with assault weapons carjacking with
pistols which are already banned I'm
talking about crime I'm talking about
murders in these towns as well give let
me just guys let me just finish my point
uh we had we got to have mental fitness
test for who can buy guns we got to have
an age limit on who can buy guns this is
what the polling says people have all
these things KY I I'll let you finish I
understand but you're not saying things
that are true when it comes to that
issue it's just true in your face
Harold I I want to I'm I'm in a
solution's business and some people are
not and that's fine if you want to be in
a political business and you want to you
want to lay out your your your agenda
that's fine but you got to hire more
cops you got to pay cops more you got to
train cops better we have to build more
prisons why because people should go to
jail who commit crimes they commit
crimes with a gun and they kill a cop
they should go to jail forever if you
commit crimes in Neighbors you're
shooting kids and black kids and brown
kids in neighborhoods where they don't
have opportunities you should go to jail
for a long long time so we can talk
about guns and I know your position on
guns but I don't like I don't like kids
having guns I don't like people who are
mentally unfit having guns and I don't
like assault weapons in neighborhoods
and that that's not carjacking that's
crime in America that we've got to deal
with what do you want to take it from
here Dana I'm just going to I don't
disagree with lot of what Katie said and
I think that what's happening for mayor
Bowser is a lot of people are just
having to make a tough decision to leave
the city they leave the city because
they can't they don't feel safe there
and they don't want to come in to work
in the city because of carjackings and
because it's not safe so what do you
have more people going into Virginia
instead of staying in the district so
they're losing a lucrative tax base and
if these kids are out doing carjackings
guess where they're not in school and
we've seen the statistics for people who
cannot read or write in The District in
the in those schools and I want to make
somebody famous you all should make him
famous too Brian Schwab he's the
Attorney General of DC he is in charge
of juvenile crime but he is focused on a
lot of different things like bringing a
case against the NRA which doesn't even
have a distri a position in the district
of Columbia so the police I would agree
hire more police but you have to allow
the police then to pursue the vehicle so
that they can catch the kids they can do
I mean there's all these things like the
air tags is basically seeding the ground
to the criminals without doing anything
else no question Greg have you been
paying attention yes I have do you have
anything to add yeah I think they should
put the air tags on the parents of these
kids idea this is how you deal with
crime once you decriminalize it it's now
on the law abiding public to adapt to
lawlessness so we won't jail them you
adapt don't go out after 9:00 p.m.
that's what people do don't wear
expensive jewelry or watches don't buy
cars that can be stolen don't take the
Subway at night anymore and while you're
at a girls don't wear short skirts see
this is the same immoral mentality that
is applying now to every single action
but there's one thing you can't do
protect yourself we no longer imprison
criminals violent criminals but if you
were to decide to protect yourself with
a firearm from these free free roaming
thugs you will be jailed it's a pincer
move that's a military phrase Brian we
get you with the crime and we get you if
you choose to defend yourself from crime
Jamal Bowman sentence which was like
writing a letter that's that's harsher
than what these kids are getting so we
live in weird times we do and I would
say this there's going to be an
opportunity in four years for a
politician to emerge we're going to have
new people if you are a mayor that
tackles criming bucks your own party the
Democratic party and starts doing some
of the things that we mentioned around
this table your whole political May of
Dallas yeah the mayor he switched
parties and if there's a Democrat
doesn't want to switch parties but take
those positions I think uh the sky is
the limit a that's a trying end on an
upbeat yeah got a lot of show left 24
minutes before the top of the hour Ione
I'm Brian killme I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that but I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now